welcome back to drizzy news right here
from washington d.c
crazy
i mean stop licking my mind
i know well before we go we'd love to
leave you with a little something to
take with you in the doggy bag
[Applause]
and here to curate we've got a local dc
style influencer and you can follow her
at blonde in the district please welcome
danny souter
thank you my god thank you so much for
having me i am so excited and i think
it's amazing
to set up everything thank you for
coming to dc and you know i i started my
blog because i wanted to show how style
can make you feel great about yourself
and wearing something amazing there's
nothing better than like going out
wearing something that you feel great in
i mean you put a smile on everyone's
face by what you're wearing and i'm glad
to know that it affects you positively
too yes and what is your pick for the dc
doggy bag a local uh dog and cat rescue
organization where my cats are from and
i know that you have rescue animals as
well so i thought that this would be the
great a great topic to talk about i
believe we both have rescue cats with
the same name same yes yes absolutely
yes
that's so cute i feel like we're like
kindred cat spirits we are okay so
so it is
lost dog and cat rescue and that's
actually where peaches and pinky their
mom and kitten they're so cute are from
and i recently adopted them this summer
and i've adopted from lost dog and cat
before as well but i really saw with
this adoption everything that goes into
running a rescue organization you know
rescue animals they bring so much joy to
your life once you have them there is no
question that when you rescue an animal
they rescue you right back absolutely
absolutely and i'd like to make a 5 000
donation to that organization
absolutely
amazing oh my gosh that is amazing thank
you i'm also going to call world's best
litter a company i work with that is the
leading donating company of kitty litter
to shelters in the country yes
i actually use their litter i saw that
yes i saw that you use it too the best
litter ever and i have a little
something for you guys that i wanted to
so inspired by
cats i recently started my own vintage
collection which is available on my
website blondethedistrict.com and i have
something on little gifts for both of
you from
oh so okay ross so this i could see you
wearing it on a blazer i know you like
color can i pull this off yes or no yeah
yeah
yes
and
drew i have the same earrings i actually
found these as a pair
and i figured that they could be i hope
that when you wear them you think of
your two rescue kitties and peach and
our kindred cat spirits so we're like
earring bffs thank you danny thank you
so much for having me
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you thank you
seriously
[Music]